the results are in for germany's
national elections and here at dw news
based in berlin we'll explain how this
might impact the asia region
we do not yet know who the next
chancellor will be
that will take time as the political
parties now negotiate
to form a coalition government
one thing to keep in mind the new
chancellor and the new foreign minister
tend to come from different parties here
are where things stand the center-left
social democrats have the tiniest of
leads with about 26 percent of the vote
the conservative cdu csu merkel's party
comes second either one could form a
coalition government with other
supporting parties
how is asia reacting to this news we
start with dw's amrita tima in india and
journalist fabian kreshmer in china
fabian it might be too soon for chinese
leadership to say anything just yet but
any early headlines from state media and
do we know what beijing most wants in
the post-miracle world
yes
angela merkel has visited china a dozen
times and at the end of her
chancellorship was actually covered
really with a lot of nostalgia by the
state media here and that should not
surprise because angela merkel is
basically um yeah the best possible
outcome also for the next government
basically her china policy was um in
beijing's eyes very
pragmatic and in a first reaction the
spokesperson of the foreign minister
ministry said that um we expect a
continuation of the pragmatic
china policy also from the next
government however um there's also a lot
of criticism for merkel's china policy
because it's quite soft and she was
rather subdued with her criticism
towards human rights what actually
beijing fears the most is that germany
will seek
tighter cooperation with america in
their china policy but if you look at
the program
of the social democrats and also the
christian democrats that is not really
likely to happen the biggest actually
criticism towards china comes from the
green party
right
amerita how is delhi watching these
results any reactions from local media
you know the local media has been
watching these elections but i have to
say the biggest and only election party
in town was at the german embassy it
wasn't the usual big bash that you have
on election night that's because of the
corona situation the numbers were kept
fairly restricted but the headlines
coming out of these elections even now
are the departure of angela merkel from
the german political stage and that's
because you know uh angela merkel
invested a huge deal in building indoor
german relations over the past 16 years
and also enjoyed a very good rapport
with prime minister narendra modi and
she made india a priority in strategic
terms so of course people are asking the
question what will her departure mean
and the media is also worried about the
fact it was such a close uh election
result that there will be uncertainty
over the coming months as a coalition
government is formed but broadly as far
beyond said people are expecting a great
deal of continuity on the broader policy
issues between india and germany for
example security how to deal with the
pandemic climate change and so on but
some changes are expected because of the
presence of the two smaller parties in
any governing coalition be there it led
by a and the spd or by the cdu that is
the greens and the business friendly ftp
now the ftp of course uh has very strong
increase in business and trade and
investment and they could set their own
accents uh and for india you know it
could be kind of bring some changes as
well as the green party because the
green party may raise issues like human
rights concerns and the crackdown on
descent and that could ruffle some
feathers within the establishment here
thank you amrita and fabian for joining
us
what will determine how germany engages
with asia depends on the kind of
coalition government the political
parties build the two most viable
options at the moment are either the
social democrats teaming up with the
greens and the libertarian free
democrats also known as the fdp or
merkel's christian democrats who came in
a tight second team me up with the same
the greens and the fdp
[Applause]
euphoria
and disappointment
as the party faithful reacted to the
numbers their bosses gathered face to
face to kick off the next fight who will
rule together
the social democrats olaf schultz moved
first
i will say that there are a few parties
who have increased their vote the spd
the greens and the fdp and the others
have not increased their share i think
that's a message
followed by this question to merkel's
choice set the tone
the question i have to ask can you
remain party leader
we don't have all the results we're
waiting for them
we've recognized today that only someone
who has a majority in the german
bundestag will become chancellor
he will need the greens and the fdp
their leader started the mind games
the greens and fdp should talk to each
other first then we can structure what
comes next
we've already made it clear in the last
few days robert habeck and i that this
logic that one calls all the others
wouldn't help the revival that we need
in this country therefore it's more than
sensible that different parties talk
with each other in different
constellations
schultz sensed the danger but seemed
confident that reaching a deal would be
easy
i have always said that there are lots
of overlaps with my neighbor but just
the two of us won't be enough it'll have
to be three parties i think we'll settle
this fairly quickly
despite the disastrous result lashit
refused to give up hope
the party in first was not always the
one that provided the chancellor
the great task of the democratic parties
is to see where there is the greatest
common ground
sounds simple enough but in germany's
multi-party system anything but
joining us in the studio is dw's chief
international editor richard walker
richard when it comes to foreign policy
is china the biggest challenge for this
next government
yeah melissa i i think you can say
pretty clearly that it is uh at the very
top of the list and that doesn't make
germany unique after all you know the
entirety of the west is really uh being
confronted and this has become into
sharpest relief in the last couple of
years really confronted with this
challenge of of a rising superpower in
china that's increasingly forthright in
its application of authoritarian power
both within its borders uh and outside
them um and particularly you know the
united states is facing the challenge of
trying to manage its intensifying
competition
with china in a way that doesn't lead to
uh the risk of of ending up in a hot war
which is which is something that many
analysts are really worried about
now for germany
this is a particularly acute situation
because germany's business ties with
china are really massive and that is
something that has emerged out of the
angela merkel eras we just heard from
fabian earlier there in beijing angela
merkel has had a very pro-engagement
policy
for the last 10 or 12 years with china
in particular and this has led to a huge
flourishing of business ties between
germany and china and germany different
from some countries in the west it
doesn't just import a lot of goods from
china it exports enormous amounts of
goods to china so some see even an
economic dependency on china so this is
a massive challenge to negotiate this
sort of tightrope walk that
that many see going ahead
now the greens have been vocal about
china's human rights record and have
pushed for a tougher position against
beijing they're very likely to be part
of any coalition government so how much
of an influence will they have on
germany's foreign policy in regards to
china
well it depends on the exact
constellation of the government as we've
just heard earlier
now we're entering this period of horse
trading between the between the parties
trying to come up with a coalition
there's a very good chance that the
greens could end up with the foreign
ministry so essentially the ministries
get dished out between the parties as
part of the coalition arrangements
the other alternative is that the free
democrats the liberal party could get
the foreign ministry and they're also
very outspoken on human rights so it's a
likely outcome of this election that
whoever is foreign minister will be have
a much stronger position on human rights
that could definitely lead to more
friction with china we heard from fabian
earlier that the spokesperson of the
foreign ministry already saying that
they seek a pragmatic relationship with
china that's the sort of thing that they
don't see as pragmatic western countries
criticizing them over their human rights
record so it could be interesting times
ahead but we should stress that in a
coalition you know no one party can
really dominate the agenda and remember
that the leading party will either be
the conservatives or the social
democrats we can expect from both of
those parties a bit more of the
continuity that we've of the approach
that broadly speaking merkel has had got
it so there will be change but perhaps
nothing too big now germany has a big
influence on eu foreign policy and of
course the eu recently released its new
indo-pacific strategy how might these
election results influence that policy
well i think you you can certainly see
whether it's the free democrats or the
greens you can see either of these two
parties wanting to take a more active
role really in shaping not just within
the eu but also uh within nato for
instance the free democrats they say
that they want to see a a clearer
strategy i'm reading from their policy
paper here
in dealing with china
cooperation with nato and democratic
partner states in asia
now this is kind of unfinished business
really from from from the end of the
angela merkel government i was just with
haiku master the outgoing foreign
minister in the united states for the
u.n general assembly talks and he was
saying to me as well that he really
wants to see the european union and the
americans and partners in the region
coming up with a much more unified
strategy of of how to deal with this
region the indo-pacific so in a way that
that is a kind of an issue that bubbled
up towards the end of the merkle
government and is now going to see new
follow-through i think either of those
parties going to be very engaged in
those debates in the years ahead richard
thank you so much for joining us
and that's it for the show there is
other news and analysis from the region
as always on our website dw.com forward
slash asia and you can follow us on
facebook and twitter as well thanks for
joining and we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye
you